في معمل على بعد 6500 ميل تقريبًا من
الباحثين في ووهان في بيركلي كاليفورنيا
يتطلعون إلى الخفافيش للعثور على أدلة حول كيفية
مساعدة البشر على محاربة فيروسات كورونا مثل
copa90 ولكن أعتقد بطريقة ما أن
هناك الكثير في الواقع يمكننا تعلمه من الخفافيش
التي تعرفها هذه المجموعة من الحيوانات
كنا موجودين منذ ملايين السنين ، كيف
يمكننا أن ننظر إلى تاريخهم مع
الفيروسات ونأخذ هذه المعرفة
ونفكر في العلاجات والعلاجات
لأنفسنا
يعتقد العلماء أن فهم
نظام مناعة الخفافيش يمكن أن يساعد في تطوير
خطة المعركة البشرية لمكافحة هذه
الأمراض على نطاق عالمي  إنها
فرصة ، ماذا عن
وحدة التمثيل الغذائي للخفافيش أو علم وظائف الأعضاء
الذي حصلوا عليه والذي يمكننا استخدامه والذي قد
يحمل في الواقع إجابة لعلاج
الفيروس إذا كان بإمكان الخفافيش التعامل مع الآلاف من
الفيروسات المختلفة ولكن حمولة أعلى
بكثير مما يستطيع البشر اكتشافه  لماذا
يعتقد العلماء أن الكود 19 قد يكون له
جذوره في مجتمع من خفافيش حدوة الحصان
في جنوب شرق الصين
والاستخدام.  تمثل الخفافيش المتحدرة مجموعة فرعية صغيرة جدًا
من الخفافيش على شكل حدوة حصان ، والتي تم تسميتها جميعًا بناءً
على شكل أنوفها ، في الواقع ، هناك
تنوع مذهل بين تلك الأنواع
يمكن العثور عليها في جميع أنحاء
العالم في كل قارة باستثناء القارة
القطبية الجنوبية ،
ولكن التنوع
والقدرات الفريدة للخفافيش هي أيضًا  ما يجعل من
الصعب مواجهتها عندما يتعلق
الأمر بالمرض ، فهي الثدييات الوحيدة
القادرة على الطيران فعليًا حتى تتمكن من
نشر الفيروسات بسهولة إلى حيوانات أخرى
في المجتمعات ، تهاجر بعض أنواع الخفافيش في الواقع
آلاف الأميال ، وبالتالي
الفيروسات التي تنقلها على طول
طرق الهجرة هذه وعلى الرغم
من أن بعض الخفافيش الممرضة تلعب دور المضيف
لتسبب لهم المرض مثل داء الكلب ، إلا أنها
تتمتع أيضًا بقدرة فريدة على استضافة
بعض الفيروسات ومقاومتها دون الإصابة
بالمرض.
مسببات الأمراض
بشكل عام لديهم بيولوجيا فريدة من
نوعها ويسمح لهم بالتعايش
مع المرضي  العشائر بطرق مختلفة